12 bricks have already opened accounts
here that's a lot of wrecks yeah
one of the best parts of a Blockbuster
movie or a hit TV series is the behind
the scenes bloopers that have fans
laughing until they cry but what about
the bloopers that actually make it into
the Final Cut welcome back the things
fans have you ever thought you caught a
glimpse of an actor laughing in a super
serious scene or caught a moment on
screen that looked a little too real to
be acting actors jobs are to bring
characters to life and make them seem
like real people well the truth is that
a lot of the time actors do this by
being real or themselves in this video
we'll be taking you through some of the
most shocking unscripted on-screen
moments with actors like Millie Bobby
Brown Tom Holland and Hollywood Legend
Robin Williams himself buckle up this
could get real
The Stranger Things cast may be at the
beginning of their careers but they give
their all into every performance in this
season 3 scene when 11 is fighting a
possessed Billy she's so tired that she
falls back into Michael but we
discovered that Millie Bobby Brown
actually broke character in this scene
and is the one who fell back into Finn
this scene was so intense that even she
was exhausted if you look closely you
can see Finn glancing at the directors
and concern because he totally wasn't
expecting it
a creepy killer clown is bad enough
through a screen imagine seeing one in
real life that's exactly what happened
to the cast of the horror movie it the
child actress that made up the losers
Club were kept separate from Bill
Skarsgard when he was in his full
Pennywise makeup and costume I think we
all also decided me Julie that it would
be good to see him for the first time
and just be freaked out the first time
they saw him altogether was when they
were filming the infamous projector
scene
the fear on their faces is completely
real
it wasn't friends at first sight for
this superhero duo in fact it took quite
a while for Tony Stark to warm up to
Peter Parker that's why this car scene
between the two was nothing but awkward
and it's all thanks to Tom Holland
breaking character it's not a hug I'm
just grabbing the door for you we're not
we're not there yet the hug between them
was actually Tom Holland trying to be
funny and Robert Downey Jr's line
afterward about opening the car door is
him trying to save the scene
improv just works for these two in
Avengers Infinity War Tom Holland also
improvised his death scene with Robert
Downey Jr
please his line was completely
unscripted and made not only the
characters but the actors emotions more
real
the filming for this scene took a
dangerous turn there's a reason why Isla
Fisher's character Henley looks like
she's really drowning during one of her
illusion tricks Isla did all of her
stunts for this movie so during the
filming she was actually drowning
luckily nothing went terribly wrong and
we got the awesome scene that ended up
in the Final Cut
would you ever take on a role in a
horror series even if we told you that
some directors purposely scare actors on
camera to get a genuine reaction this
exact thing happened during a scene for
the hit Netflix show The Haunting of
Hill House actress Victoria pedretti as
Nell pops her head out from the back
seat of a car in order to scare her two
sisters but during one take she did it
earlier than expected the reactions from
the actresses Kate Siegel and Elizabeth
Reeser are completely real
do you remember Kevin's electric
performance of tear me down in
riverdale's season 4 musical episode
well Kevin's actor Casey Cott and KJ APA
teamed up to shock the other actors in
one scene Kevin kisses Archie it was
totally unscripted and makes the look of
shock on everyone else's faces even more
priceless
KJ APA was putting so much effort into
this scene that he actually broke his
hand during the emotional season 1
episode where Archie rescues Cheryl from
the lake where she's Trapped Under Ice
he punches away with it with his bare
hands while KJ was of course punching a
mat over the ice he still managed to
break his hand while filming the scene
bird box broke records at Netflix and
with how much work went into the film
we're not surprised one shocking fact
about the film is that Sandra Bullock
really was blindfolded during her scenes
and actually couldn't see that means
Mallory stumbling around on the scene
wasn't all acting it was very real
The Joker film was nothing short of
spectacular and a lot of it is thanks to
Joaquin Phoenix there's actually an
iconic scene included in the movie that
was all thanks to joaquin's emotions and
not acting at all one day on set he got
to hear the soundtrack to the film for
the first time his lone tier in this
scene is actually his reaction to
hearing the music
Lara Jean and Peter Kay's love story is
probably one we've all dreamed of once
in our lives but how much of it was Lara
and Peter and how much of it was their
actors Lana and Noah having fun if you
pay attention to the film Lara Jean's
lock screen is actually her and Peter
napping but according to the director
the photo on her phone was actually
taken of Lana and Noah napping together
in between takes
any kid would be scared of Maleficent
we're even scared of Maleficent that's
why for the film The only child who
would work as toddler Aurora was
Angelina Jolie's daughter Vivian the
acting in their adorable scenes together
is really just Vivian trying to get her
mother's attention
Malfoy and Crabb had a reputation to
uphold at Hogwarts so when we see Malfoy
stop his friend from clapping after a
Gryffindor Victory we think nothing of
it but the scene is actually Tom Felton
stopping his co-star from clapping
because he knew he wasn't supposed to
Tom was really trying to keep cool calm
and collected here
Gray's Anatomy has been around for years
so the actors have gotten pretty good at
their jobs but of course they still
break character every now and again in
this scene Jessica Capshaw decided to
improv a kiss between her and Camilla
Ludington the shock on Joe's face is 100
Camilla
Michael Scott's last episode of The
Office was extremely emotional for the
characters but it was also hard for the
actors to say goodbye to Steve Carell
that's why in the scene where Pam rushes
to the airport to say goodbye to Michael
the emotional performance by Jenna
Fisher wasn't a performance at all
if you ever watch Supernatural you know
that Dean's famous catchphrase is
well there was one time when Jensen
Ackles decided to add the line in when
it wasn't scripted but he said it with a
little too much enthusiasm Jared
Padalecki was not expecting it and burst
out laughing the director loved it and
decided to keep the take
Jason Siegel had no idea that his
character Marshall would be losing his
father in the series in fact the first
time he found out was when Alison
Hannigan's character told him the
emotion on his face is actually his
reaction to finding out the news
David Schwimmer managed to pull off a
practical joke on Jennifer Aniston while
filming friends and it was used in an
episode he along with his sidekick Cole
Sprouse pretended like he had fallen
down the stairs but it was really only a
dummy that fell Jennifer had no idea it
was going to happen so Rachel's panic
and screams in the scene were really
Jennifer freaking out
Robin Williams was of course a comedic
genius in Goodwill Hunting during a
therapy scene with Matt Damon he tells
him a hilarious story about the
flatulence problem his character's wife
had the story was so funny because it
was completely made up by Robin Matt
Damon smiles and laughs are all real
pretty woman is a Hollywood classic and
Millennials today still strive to have
the aesthetic Julia Roberts brought to
that screen we're here to tell you that
one of the most iconic scenes was in
fact completely unscripted when Julia
Roberts gets her hand caught in the
jewelry box that Richard Gere closes her
reaction wasn't acting she had no idea
that he was going to do that at all
what can we say the best moments in life
on and off screen are unscripted let's
just take a second to imagine what these
movies and series would look like
without some of these scenes sometimes
unscripted moments breathe more life
into a scene the adults are talking and
other times they I'm so sorry fall short
luckily in the MCU the improvisation
Gene is impeccably strong amongst its
actors so in this video we're taking you
through all of Spider-Man's unscripted
moments that completely took the films
to another level action we all know Tony
Stark isn't one to get himself caught up
in emotional moments and in Spider-Man
homecoming Peter Parker learns that in a
pretty awkward way after Tony Stark has
a talked with Peter in his car he
reaches over to open the car door but
Peter thinks he's actually leaning in
for a hug remember
it's not a hug I'm just grabbing the
door for you well check out what Tom
Holland had to say about the scene well
that was actually an improvised moment I
think I just tried to hug him I just
thought it would be funny if I hugged
him and the hilarious moment was
completely improvised for laughs but
Robert Downey Jr went along with it
speaking about Tony Stark and his
emotions during the final moments of
Avengers Infinity War he was nothing but
emotional same Mr Stark as Spider-Man
turned into nothingness in his arms we
were all a puddle of Tears when he
desperately chants
that was all Tom Holland again the
director gave him free reign on the
death scene and Tom delivered even if he
doesn't think it was that spectacular
himself I don't want to go three times
in a row so it's not that amazing of an
ad-lib it's hard to believe Spider-Man
is one of Tom's first big roles Tom
Holland and Zendaya's chemistry is off
the charts Peter Parker and MJ are like
magic on screen together and a lot of
that is that thanks to the actors
off-screen friendship according to
Zendaya Tom has a habit of deviating
from the script but thankfully they're
so in tune with one another that she was
able to respond right back no matter how
annoyed she was which is kept improving
he just did not stick to the script he
was trying to throw me off what's your
favorite Peter in MJ scene she knows I
told her
he didn't tell me I figured it out if
there's one thing better than watching
Peter and MJ on screen it's watching
Peter MJ and Ned interact with one
another but the truth is a lot of the
time we're watching their off-screen
relationships shine through the camera
remember in Spider-Man far from home Ned
walks in on MJ and Peter while he's
changing into his Spider-Man suit the
costume looks great
for the costume party well Ned wasn't in
on the fact that MJ had found out their
secret and tried to play it off Ned's
actor Jacob batalon actually said that
was one of his favorite scenes to shoot
because he got to improv all his
comments there was a lot of laughter on
set that day we have to give Jake
Gyllenhaal credit for playing such a
convincing role as Mysterio who knew
that he would actually turn out as a
villain in the end but it looks like we
should be praising Jake for more than
just his impeccable acting skills
according to the actor Pian director
John Watts came up with a lot of
unscripted moments for his character
that ended up in the film we don't know
what specific scenes these moments are
in but let's just appreciate Mysterio
for a sec somebody get this stupid
costume off me having at may be played
by a younger actress in the Marvel
Universe gave us a whole other
perspective on her relationship with
Peter it's so comforting to see the two
of them interact on screen but you'll be
shocked to find out that a lot of their
scenes were unscripted as well one
specific improvised moment in Spider-Man
homecoming happened by while they're
eating in the Thai restaurant sometimes
you have to say larb before
you talk to me
larby their conversation was just
something the actor made up on the fly
with some guidance from the director yet
again we have another improvised moment
between Peter Parker and Tony Stark this
time it's in Captain America's Civil War
check it out
I'm gonna sit here so you move the leg
Tony Stark telling Peter to move over
might seem like it was in character and
it is but it was also Robert Downey Jr's
way of telling Tom Holland to scoot over
onto his set marker without ruining the
entire take funnily enough it ended up
in the Final Cut can you even see in
these yes yes
Samuel L Jackson got his moment to shine
in Spider-Man as his character Nick Fury
he even got sassy with Spider-Man
although the line wasn't even scripted
when Peter admits he's a little hesitant
to join their newest plan Fury says
please you've been to space Samuel
L Jackson may not have recalled whether
the line was improvised but Jake
Gyllenhaal jumped in to confirm it was
100 unscripted I'm here to attest that
was improvised despite his hesitancy
with Nick Fury Peter was all in for
helping out Iron Man on his Avengers
Infinity War Mission but Tony Stark
wasn't having it or should we say Robert
Downey Jr wasn't having it while Iron
Man is having a discussion with Doctor
Strange Peter chimes in that he's back
up I'm back up you're still away the
adults are talking but that was yet
again another improvised line between
the unscripted heroes Tom Holland and
Robert Downey Jr Spider-Man far from
home is full of European landmarks that
make the entire movie stunning even if a
lot of them do get destroyed according
to a Screen Rant interviewer a lot of
improvising happened in a specific
Landmark The London Tower the film's
final battle takes place in London and
supposedly during this scene the cast
shot so many versions because of their
ability to improvise you'd never be able
to tell in the Final Cut they joined
forces like the Power Rangers you think
you can Voltron Voltron you think you
have Voltron drax's line I'll do you one
better why is Gamora is one of the
funniest highlights that came out of
Avengers Infinity War even if
Spider-Man's life was literally being
threatened in the scene the line however
was actually ad-libbed by drax's actor
Dave Batista the rest of the actors
including Tom Holland are just so
professional that they rolled with it
the camera operator even seemed to be
quick to react Michael Keaton got some
time to shine in Spider-Man homecoming
but one of his best lines didn't make
the final cut according to Tom Holland
Keaton actually made a direct reference
to his role as Batman in the 80s his
character vulture is a little confused
as to why Spider-Man would save him and
after Tom Holland delivers his because
I'm Spider-Man Keaton supposedly
responded but I'm Batman we don't know
if the line was part of the script but
Tom Holland seemed to be hinting it was
ad-libbed like we mentioned before Jake
Gyllenhaal played the perfect Mysterio
and a lot of why his character is so
epic may be because of how well he got
along with Tom Holland according to Tom
Mysterio and Spider-Man were actually
meant to bump heads a lot however while
filming their interactions turned out to
be more friendly the directors decided
to let them head off the script and
build their own relationship between the
characters they basically became BFFs
good luck kid I'll give you about a 50
50 chance you're pretty awkward so we
also see spidey's actual BFF Ned get his
own romantic interest but according to
Ned's actor Jacob batalon Ned's
relationship with Betty was basically
developed by him and actress and gory
rice he says they were given a lot of
space for improv they may not have
lasted super long as a couple but
there's no doubt they were adorable I
would totally kiss you but I think I
just threw up in my mouth a little I I
might have a mint it seems like Jacob
batalon had a lot to do with all his
characters relationships with the
chemistry between Peter and Ned we've
never doubted the way they were
childhood best friends and The Chemistry
Between the actress off screen is why
it's so authentic apparently because Tom
and Jacob weren't given the script days
in advance they never knew their lines
which means their interactions are
purely the two actors playing off one
another
well yeah we met
more failure if we needed any more proof
that Tom Holland is holding his own when
it comes to the rest of the Marvel cast
this video is it watching these actors
not only play superheroes but be
superheroes when it comes to Bringing to
life a character is nothing short of
impressive let us know if you have any
other unscripted Spider-Man moments we
should discuss some of our favorite
lines and animated films are actually
happy accidents you'd be surprised by
how many iconic scenes were improvised
by actors in the recording booth we've
got 15 of our favorite improvised
moments in animated films coming right
up we know exactly what to do
number one
a talk about Bruno how could not discuss
His Brilliant ad-lib that brought a rat
telenovela to the film their love could
never
jean-luizamo was given the chance by
directors Byron Howard and Jared Bush to
improvise a bit in the booth and thank
goodness he did this was just one of his
additions throughout his performance
there are different shades of the actor
that come through it may be small but
it's also comic genius
number two
Luisa was having a bit of a meltdown
heavy the strong Lisa wasn't feeling so
hot and Jessica Darrow brought all the
agony she could into the booth to
capture the true drama and spirit of the
moment the team had the actress
improvising some sounds of Agony and
cries the actress was pretty into it so
she asked if she could take it a step
further and throw in some actual
dialogue and then this happened
yeah it was a heartbreaker but the
production team knew it was perfect in
the context of the story this improv
line even caught the Luis actress off
guard she had no idea it was going to be
part of the film until she was watching
the final cut herself number three
not all improv is funny one of the most
touching moments in Raya and The Last
Dragon is when Raya takes a moment to
herself to pray
if I can be honest and a whole lot of it
was dialogue coming straight from actor
Kelly Marie Tran she explained I
remember asking if I could try something
different because I remember what it
felt like to be desperate and I remember
how I acted in those moments and what it
felt like to pray to a being in this
case Rai is praying to see Sue that
you're not even sure exists you're just
that desperate
number four if we have time for a few
more jokes she'll tell him Aquafina is a
jokester in her own life so whenever she
came across a joke written in the script
the actor would ask let me try just a
few more what were they gonna say no
well we still have a big chunk of it
since the part was written with her
voice in mind it only made sense
number five this could probably be
considered a special skill if you need
someone who can belch on command Luca
actor Jacob Tremblay is your guy
when the Luca team was recording and
they came to the part in the script
where Luca was meant to let out a burp
Tremblay figured he'd offer his Services
I was able to give them some cool sound
bites and they ended up using my burp in
the film Tremblay loved the experience
of improvising especially with the
encouragement of his director Enrico
casarosa who let me bring a lot of that
into the experience
number six if it's good you find a way
to make it work Sasha Baron Cohen's Ugo
wasn't even a character at first so he
didn't end up being part of too many
scenes but then the team got a whole lot
of great content from the actor in the
booth some people think I'm mad to live
in the Deep for director casarosa it was
a pleasure to see Cohen came in and he
improvised so much that we even put a
little button at the end of our movie to
contain more of the improvisation that
he did for us because he was so fun if
it works you better work it I think that
they are the ones who are mad not me the
one who is mad it's dead
number seven
it's a fight sure but it's a hilarious
fight when Barney and Ron find
themselves on the Run for the Bubble
company they get into a bit of a scuffle
have you got water damage to the brain I
mean seriously but it was all Zach
Galifianakis and Jack Dylan Grazer the
performers actually had a special
session together in the recording booth
just to improvise the fight their improv
was riddled with comedy gold so instead
of sticking with what was planned the
animators literally just took their
dialogue and made the animation fit what
they said it was too good not to use it
was a wild experience for sure the Ron
actor explaining it's weird because you
don't know the person just like with
anything else you're working on you have
to act like you know them since they
weren't meant to be longtime Pals in the
movie anyway it definitely helped bring
some authenticity to the film
number eight
Lena was bringing herself to this film
it's a short and quick line but this my
girlfriend's daughter got me pulling my
hair out okay is in fact not what was
originally in the script when the
Specter actor was recording she swapped
the word husband for girlfriend just
wanting to be her authentic self in that
moment the team was caught off guard but
they were all for it it's not easy being
a new parent number nine
say hello to a Dream Team it was magical
it was magical he and peel have a pretty
special relationship and they brought
all those Good Vibes to the table when
they were recording their lines for Toy
Story 4. you got a kid like like a kid
kid like a human kid one very special
moment is the five or so seconds of an
original rap that's heard in the film
for these two it just made sense we sing
to each other and so it was something
that came up in the creating of the
characters within the story that's just
a taste of the Improv the Dual actually
sang three songs and the team recorded
three minutes worth but in the end we
only got five seconds we'll just be here
waiting for the full album release
number 10.
the actor himself didn't know this would
be included Josh Gad was maybe the most
surprised to find out just how much of
his improv made it to the Frozen films
[Music]
the scene up to his big number when I am
older and Frozen two was one of the best
bits he brought to the film Gad
explained it never ceases to amaze me
that I'm allowed to improv something
clinically insane in a sound booth and
then the best animators in the world
take my nonsense and bring it to life
over thousands of hours considering how
good it is we're not surprised
number 11.
his name is Olaf and guess what and I
like warm hugs this might just be the
most adorable improvised line there is
God explained improv has been such an
essential part of my journey in creating
Olaf that came from Jen and Chris saying
this character represented Youth and
naivete and those two worlds allowed me
to just explore and find these
non-sequiturs that made the character
Spark
number 12.
when it comes to Dragon Training improv
is a must Jay Baruchel was free to do
his thing in the How to Train Your
Dragon recording booth and had some
excellent improv included in the Final
Cut like this Shady insult thank you for
nothing you useless reptile and of
course some of hiccups Grim vibes
number 13 with this actor in the booth
improv is hard to avoid all hail Kristen
Wiig an improv genius who according to
the team was able to make anything sound
funny and maybe most importantly willing
to take anything to the most ridiculous
degree her improv was scattered
throughout the How to Train Your Dragon
recording sessions but one of the best
scenes that was full of wig's
spontaneous lines and moments saw her
annoying the heck out of grimall as
possibly the most annoying prisoner he'd
ever dealt with
number 14 it was subtle but it spoke
volumes in the original script Gober was
meant to tell hiccup about why valka and
stoef were so tense with each other and
explaining that's the reason why he
didn't get married but what he wasn't
meant to say was
this and one other reason after Craig
Ferguson was the one responsible for
adding that small detail and director
Dean de blois felt they should include
it because in his own words I think it's
nice it's Progressive it's honest and it
feels good so we wanted to keep it
number 15 use what you know Elizabeth
Debicki was maybe a bit too good at this
the actress was improvising like a
master in the booth for Peter Rabbit too
but then director will Glock reigned on
her parade saying she was probably just
drawing on my own personal experience of
being an incredibly bossy big sister I
have two siblings and I'm so bossy and
will probably had to be like could you
just be a little less it's a children's
film and to think this was just a taste
of the feistiness she brought take that
off what are you genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist
which Marvel film had a whopping 80
percent of scenes unscripted today we're
taking a look at memorable and hilarious
Marvel moments that were made up
completely on the spot one MCU character
name dropped a major celebrity any ideas
why how did a very special visitor
contribute directly to a very memorable
improvised line people walking around
saying wakanda forever
episode 2 of the Loki series brings a
very random yet perfectly improvised
line remember Loki's odd candy comment
candies
snots
Hiddleston came up with that on the spot
and it was just too good not to make the
final cut director Kate Herron even
highlighted it as one of her favorite
moments that never fails to make her
laugh we are not doing get help director
taika waititi was super collaborative on
the set of Thor Ragnarok which was a
pretty big reason for the 80 of dialogue
in the movie that ended up being
completely improvised before shooting
the brilliant get help scene YTD
suggested that Chris Hemsworth and Tom
Hiddleston do the scene as if they were
playing a game from childhood after
exploring the idea for a bit the scene
was improvised from there classic I
still hated it's humiliation why TD does
credit Hemsworth for coming up with the
idea of Thor convincing Loki to go ahead
with his plan apparently Beyonce exists
in the MCU at least according to Dr
Strange himself Benedict Cumberbatch
try me Beyonce
the Beyonce reference was tossed in
while Cumberbatch was improvising his
way through the scene Wong said that for
the most part he was just listening and
responding to cumberbatch's instincts
the actors were really surprised by just
how hilarious the material they came up
with was the moment was of course made
even better by having Wong listening to
Beyonce for his supposed research later
on and he transformed back into himself
and he was like yeah it's me and he
stopped me Four's childhood snake story
comes directly from Chris Hemsworth the
actor had actually come up with a number
of different ideas in his improvs but
the snake memory wound up being the
perfect fit
so
who would like to start while on set for
Falcon and the Winter Soldier Anthony
Mackey and Sebastian Stan were given the
framework of how the therapy scene
should go but aside from that the actors
were left to their own devices you
really enjoyed us I'm going to I know
you are yeah the result was a fantastic
display of Maki and Stan's improv skills
as well as their deep knowledge and
connection to their characters even
small details like their interlocking
legs were Natural Instincts only four or
five takes were filmed at each angle
which is significantly less than usual
drink I like it I know that's great
right another the cast and crew were
extremely surprised to have Thor
throwing his mug after requesting more
coffee the spontaneous Choice proved to
be very popular with the Marvel
president so of course it made the cut
seeing this referenced in Loki again is
a great moment just going to show that
sometimes these golden improvs become
part of the world and we love to see it
the crew of Avengers Infinity War got
quite the surprise when Winston Duke and
other actors in the film started doing
some chants in unison that they'd never
heard before
[Applause]
black panther was still in production at
that point so only to cast members who
were in both films knew what was going
on the surprise moment turned out to be
a hit and made the Final Cut having
these appear in both films was a great
way to tie the movies together as well
no
surprising that one of the
one of the all of Avengers Infinity war
was completely improvised by the actors
vision's heartbreaking death scene was
actually ad-libbed by Elizabeth Olsen
and Paul Bettany the actors knew where
they had to go with the scene so the
director told them to just follow their
instincts and we got the magic that we
see in the movie we are out of time
the actors were actually really freaked
out in the moments they were filming
realizing just how much they were
actually needing to improvise they wound
up joking a lot together making filming
the scene a very fun and silly process
this thing looked like
Coulson talk like him too the moment
that Nick Fury peeks under the blanket
on scroll is pretty much gold and an
idea that came in the moment from Samuel
L Jackson director Ryan Fleck really
enjoyed the spontaneous move and after
looking back at the footage the team
agreed that it was too good not to keep
in the Final Cut dance off bro me and
you
Chris Pratt AKA Peter Quill's real life
clumsiness came in very handy during
filming of Guardians of the Galaxy he
managed to bring this great moment to
life when he nearly dropped the orb but
it was actually completely by accident
it ended up fitting the moment so well
though so the take was kept
congratulations
fair game Karen Gillen initiated a game
of paper football with Robert Downey Jr
floating in space and the cameras loved
it so who is the paper football champ
Gillen has insisted that she was the
winner since she was the one that
started the match
I'm gonna sit here so you move the leg
in America civil Robert Downey Jr
Tom Holland his selling Peter Parker to
move was quite literally a direction
Holland had forgotten his blocking so
instead of breaking character the
Captain America actor pushed through the
scene and made what needed to happen
happen the team loved it so of course it
made the movie
hey we know each other he's a friend
from work this improv idea didn't
actually come from any of the actors it
was a suggestion made by a very special
guest on the set one day a young fan
from Make-a-Wish was talking to
Hemsworth between takes and said that
Thor should say Hulk was a friend from
work the actor took it seriously and
brought the funny line to life that kid
definitely has some good instincts one
of the most epic lines that came up on
the spot in the MCU was definitely
Robert Downey Jr's proclaiming he was
Iron Man
and
Iron Man he completely surprised the
filming crew when he did it and brought
an extremely memorable moment to our
screens
we won
to start when Robert Downey Jr is on set
brilliant improv isn't too far away his
final scene in Avengers end game was
fully unscripted the team of course laid
out an outline and explained what points
needed to be hit in the scene but
otherwise Downey Jr and Tom Holland were
left to make improv magic together
Holland said it was extremely emotional
to film especially with the small amount
of people that were actually present for
filming nobody would know
nobody Jeremy renner's sidebar teasing
remark at Pietro while rambling to
himself as Hawkeye was born in the
moment and Renner committed so well it
made for one of the funniest bits in the
whole movie one simple word changed the
meaning and amped this line up to be one
of the most memorable snide remarks in
Avengers Infinity War Drax actor David
Bautista changed the word where to why
and made movie Magic with his line of
okamora who's Gamora I'll do you one
better why is Gamora screenwriter
Christopher Marcus was very impressed
with the Improv and gives total credit
to Bautista for it
please Peter Parker's final moments in
Avengers Infinity war was actually
inspired by a long improvisation the
team had done while shooting in it they
found the incredible moment that Holland
has talking about how he doesn't want to
go and made sure to add it to the movie
this emotional moment came from a simple
direction to just act like he didn't
want to go and Holland nailed it
The Avengers post-credits scene that had
the crew eating shawarma in a
half-destroyed restaurant was totally
inspired by one of Robert Downey Jr's
improvised lines in an earlier scene you
ever tried Shawarma there's a shawarma
joint about two blocks from here I don't
know what it is but I want to try it he
threw the reference in after taking care
of Loki and considering how hard they
were working we wouldn't be surprised if
the actor was actually just hungry
Evangeline Lily and Paul Rudd punching
it out makes for a great scene in the
2015 film Ant-Man but what makes it even
better is Rudd's improvised lines the
Ant-Man actor regularly threw in witty
one-liners throughout the film but one
golden moment really stuck out to us
after being nailed by Lily Rod quips
were you going for the hand nice try
Ant-Man we have a feeling her aim is
pretty accurate that's how you punch I
dropped some eggs you like accidentally
made the guy stranger things is one of
the biggest TV hits of all time do you
in large part to its amazing cast along
with being incredible actors it turns
out that there are also some seriously
impressive improvisers even though the
show is scripted some of the most
impactful moments from all three seasons
were actually improv like some
hilariously awkward unscripted moments
that even the most professional actors
couldn't keep a straight face for it was
not written in the script because it was
not written one of the most infamous
unscripted moments in stranger things
history was the kiss between Max and
Lucas in season two well the actress
behind Max Sadie sink who was only 15 at
the time and had never been kissed was
not told about the big moment before
arriving on set but when Ross Duffer
joked about it and she freaked out and
became extremely uncomfortable he
decided that he just had to add it in
just to mess with her he said in an
interview that it was her fault that the
kiss was added in because she reacted so
nervously you were so freaked out that I
was like well I gotta make her do it now
uh do you remember being 15 we do and
having our first kiss in front of a crew
of hundreds would have freaked us out
too even though it all turned out okay
in the end the moment sparked an
important conversation about advocating
for the rights of young actors on set
Millie Bobby Brown and Finn wolfhard
have grown super close over the course
of filming stranger things which makes
for some amazing on-screen chemistry
just check out this adorable scene of
the two of them playing around
I never gave up on you I heard you can't
fake that kind of friendship which is
what makes the fact that they're very
sweet scene in the grocery store from
season three was actually all improv
even better poor Mike is struggling to
find the words to tell Elle that he
wants to get back together with her and
we all know how hard that can be I just
like I've never felt like this you know
with anyone before so when Finn started
going off script and trying to find a
way to confess his love for her the
director is absolutely loved it and told
him to keep going like old people say to
each other sometimes old people yeah
some actors will do just about anything
to stay in character even when it
terrifies their co-stars just ask anyone
who's ever worked with Jared Leto is he
crazy well it turns out that daker
Montgomery who plays the only human
being who has ever been intimidating in
a mullet Billy takes after Leto in his
own way daker was so determined to stay
in character as his psychotic possessed
by evil forces character that he threw
caution to the wind and almost broke his
own skull during a take I've done things
back really
bad things in the harrowing sauna
sequence from Season Three Billy was
only supposed to scream at the kids from
behind the sauna window but instead he
went ahead and smashed his head against
the thick glass so hard that it actually
shattered luckily he walked away with no
lasting injuries and no one can say the
reactions he got from the kids weren't
totally authentic Max get away from the
door what
get away from the door the entire sauna
episode was no easy feat not for anyone
involved apparently it took four days to
shoot the emotionally rot sequence and
by the end of it everyone was completely
exhausted no one more so than Millie
Bobby Brown whose Showdown against Billy
drained both the character and the actor
physically and psychologically I was
walking every single day director Sean
Levy said that all of the exhaustion you
see on screen is completely real and
that the moment when 11 collapses into
Mike's arms and starts sobbing wasn't in
the script at all but was just the
actress herself falling apart and we
don't blame her you can see Finn
breaking character and looking over at
the director for guidance before
wrapping his arms around Millie to
comfort her she's such a dedicated
actress that it's easy to forget how
young she is and what a toll this kind
of work must take after so long 11 is me
like 11 is just who I am now even though
he had tormented her and everyone around
her for the entire third season when it
came to the final moments between Billy
and eleven Millie Bobby Brown decides to
show some empathy for his incredibly
tortured character right at the very end
11 season to Billy's memories and
reminds him of a day at the beach with
his mother long before everything went
wrong in his life turning him into a
monster he told her
the wave was seven feet while it wasn't
in the script she reaches up and touches
his face which when you think about it
is probably one of the only times that
Billy has ever experienced real kindness
since his mother passed away moving on
to something a little less tragic
remember the hilarious breakfast scene
between Nancy Murray and Jonathan you
know the morning after while it turns
out that one of the funniest parts of
that cringe-worthy brunch was entirely
made up
Brett Gelman who plays Murray is one of
the best comic actors out there and when
he saw an opportunity to make the
painful scene even more uncomfortable he
had to take it right after asking a few
innuendo heavy questions about how their
night on the pull-out couch was Gelman
accidentally dropped a fork full of eggs
instead of just picking it up and
continuing he instead said this oops you
can clearly see Natalia Dyer doing her
best not to burst out laughing at the
ad-lib and we don't know if we could
have been that strong either all right
David Harbor's Hopper try saying that
three times is one of the highlights of
the show even if he can be seriously
grumpy sometimes but his grumpiness
really does come from a place of love
and it only makes his character more
endearing when
you stop talking right change while he
has said that he doesn't improvise a ton
of lines he adds in a lot of different
behaviors that are definitely not on the
page one example of this kind of thing
goes all the way back to season one on
the page it was really written as a
sweet caring scene but instead Harbor
decided that Hopper would try to get
Jonathan to toughen up and approached it
from a way tougher place even going so
far as to punch him on the shoulder
you're crazy see crazy
you want to see real crazy back when she
was first getting to develop the
character of 11. Millie Bobby Brown
decided that she wanted to find a few
moments where the young girl could be a
little bit funny even if that wasn't in
the script at all one of her most iconic
moments was totally improv that's right
it's the eggo scene in The Script they
had 11 go to the fridge and pull out one
or maybe two boxes of waffles but
instead Millie had the idea to take just
about as many as she could carry and
honestly who can't relate to that excuse
me young lady Holly wheeler Nancy's
younger sister has been on the show
since the very beginning and you might
be surprised to hear that she's actually
played by two twins Anderson and Tinsley
price the price sisters were only two
years old when they started filming the
show so they weren't given a whole lot
of lines none in fact literally
everything that Holly has ever said on
screen has been improv and most of her
reactions as well
it's okay Ollie it's just a loud noise
it turns out that two-year-olds are
pretty Priceless in their reactions so
if you turn a camera on them you're
bound to get something great I'm gonna
blow some daylight into that thick skull
of yours no Hopper has had some great
fights in stranger things history but
his battle with Gregory was one of the
best and apparently all it said in the
original script was they fight which
isn't much to go off of but working with
their stunt coordinator they had a great
time coming up with the epic showdown
and based most of it off of the Indiana
Jones movie Raiders of the Lost Ark they
even got to throw some action hero lines
of their own into it you won't do that
why is that because you're a policeman
forever
hey twyhearts
everything there is to know about the
Twilight Saga well this video might just
change that the Twilight cast are all
amazing actors but they have a hidden
talent improv did you know that Bella
and Edward's Treetop scene was actually
unscripted Robert just kept ad-libbing
that's why in this video we'll be going
over all the surprising Twilight Saga
moments where the actors weren't really
acting
than an older woman huh
when Bella meets the Cullens for the
first time the only thing better than
Rosalie's sass the entire family will be
implicated if this ends badly I would
become the male is when Edward takes
Bella up to the Treetops of the forest
it's the first time Bella and the
audience get to see him in action well
Kristen Stewart revealed that Robert
Pattinson actually ad-libbed one of the
most popular lines of the scene Bella is
basically questioning everything that's
going on in this scene who wouldn't and
when she says this kind of stuff just
doesn't exist doesn't my world Edward's
response was all Rob according to
Kristen
that wasn't the only part of the treetop
scene that Rob pulled out of his back
pocket now this next line is actually
pretty controversial in the way that
people literally get secondhand
embarrassment when they hear it are you
ready you better hold on tight spider
monkey director Catherine Hardwick had
been trying to find a line that would
work for the moment and that's what Rob
came up with honestly it makes us think
whether or not the ad-lib was meant to
be a joke considering how honest Rob's
been with how ridiculous he thinks the
Twilight scripts are so if you've been
wondering exactly what a spider monkey
is for the last decade try asking rpats
after watching Four movies we all know
how attracted vampires are to Bella's
scent you do smell good anyone else
still kind of creeped out about that so
in a clipse when Jacob helps carry her
through the forest to create a false
Trail it makes total sense but filming
the scene was actually pretty difficult
Taylor Lautner may have a toned body but
he isn't as strong as a werewolf they
had a lever that was meant to hold
Kristen so that Taylor could deliver
basically a four minute monologue but it
didn't work out Taylor improvised
toughened it out and just carried
Kristen himself the crew was probably
extremely grateful for his improvisation
drowning is scary no doubt about it but
apparently so is pretending to drown
after Bella's cliff diving Escapade she
almost meets her demise when filming
that scene Kristen actually had to get
in a body of water with weights in her
Pockets to make it seem more real the
fear on her face in the scene wasn't
scripted it's all Kristen the director
Chris Wheats finally decided to remove
the weights after trying it out himself
stage 20 and things are just getting
stranger Kristin's favorite scene in the
entire film was completely improvised
but it got deleted according to the
actress it was just a casual moment
between Kristen and Edward where they
were only told to have a conversation
they thought their characters would be
having I don't think I could take care
of myself I know you can't
the filmmakers thought the scene wasn't
worth the Final Cut but Kristen totally
disagrees
what's a wolf thing Taylor Lautner
didn't really get the whole concept of
imprinting same Taylor same so when he
was given a script with no instruction
on how to make it look like he was
imprinting on a literal newborn he knew
he had to improvise the entire moment so
Not only was the whole moment thought Up
by Taylor Renesmee was completely done
later on in the editing room that means
to top it all off he imprinted on an
invisible baby it's like gravity your
whole Center shifts that's a tough one
we're not going to lie luckily Stephanie
Meyer was on set for moral support and
to re-explain what imprinting was
time the Cullen's baseball scene might
just be the most iconic scene and not
even just the Twilight film but the
Twilight book vampires playing baseball
during a thunderstorm does it even get
better than that hey come on it's just a
game well what we're about to tell you
might just be the cherry on top of a
perfect scene Jackson Rathbone
improvised all of his skills with his
Bat actually he didn't even know he was
being filmed he was just fooling around
between takes and the cameras just
happened to be rolling in this not CGI
and I can still do it to this day with
some editing the b-roll became the
a-roll Jackson do you have real-life
Vampire Skills you've been hiding
speaking of Jackson he had another scene
where he added his own tidbit to the
script remember when he went all newborn
and tried to attack Bella at her
birthday party in New Moon well the
scene was actually more intense than it
was meant to be thanks to Jackson he got
so in character that he actually got
other actors Peter Facinelli and Kellen
Lutz to hold him back because he was
starting to terrify Kristen that's some
major method acting Jackson
it's okay it's just a little blood
moving on to another major fight in
Twilight we have the final showdown
between Edward and James in the ballet
studio you're faster than the other s
but not stronger
vampire fights are intense which means
to prep they bring in stunt doubles and
get the actors to learn fight
choreography so no one gets hurt but
Robert and cam jagande decided to Veer
off the choreography and improvise their
own fight instead their unscripted moves
may have just been for fun but they
ended up making the final cut it must
have looked more natural
Jessica may get jealous of Bella and
Edward sometimes but she was still there
to cheer Bella up during new moon and
have a girls night out but Anna Kendrick
took the scene a whole step further now
that she's gone on to do other
franchises like Pitch Perfect we know
how amazing she is however check out
what she did before she was starring in
all these Blockbusters I want to sit
through all those zombies eating people
and no hot guys kissing anybody her
entire monologue about the trash zombie
movie in this scene was improvised the
entire thing kudos to her that must not
have been an easy thing to keep on
reshooting perfectly
beauty is pain right at least for
vampires in the Twilight Saga it is the
transition process is painful but at
least the actors had some fun filming
the scenes when Robert filmed Edward's
transition scene with Peter Facinelli it
was all silent that means when Peter
went to lean into Rob's ear he could
literally say anything so every time
they shot the scene he would improvise
something different the first thing I
said I'm sorry it started off normal but
by the end he was whispering stuff like
you're attractive they struggled to keep
a straight face the entire time okay so
maybe filming the scene was painful in
another way
I've held her once and already you think
that you have wolfy claim on her so to
be fair on-screen babies don't really
act they're just there but the baby who
was playing Renesmee during her birth
scene was having a little too much fun
instead of fake blood the costume
Department had to use a mix of jelly and
cream cheese so they wouldn't irritate
her skin well the baby thought it was
delicious you can actually see them
trying to lick the spreads throughout
the entire birth scene honestly this
might be the most adorable improv moment
without this video we probably would
have had no idea how many scenes were
actually improvised Hold On Tight spider
monkey that line is basically iconic and
it was all our hats no wonder the entire
cast are such huge actors even more than
a decade later what was your favorite
improvised scene do you know of any
other unscripted moments